et nous allons maintenant parler
d'ingénierie industriel avec notamment
le Groupe SEGULA technologique est
engagé dans l'aéronautique notamment pas
que et pour parler de SEGULA
Technologies qui est présent bien
évidemment à 50 ans en Yvelines sur son
site à attrape nous allons parler de ça
marque de design industriel technique
icône avec Frédéric Loisel bonjour
bonjour responsable Commerce et
Marketing de cette filiale alors déjà un
mot sur cette finale qu'est-ce que c'est
alors c'est la marque du design
industriel du Groupe SEGULA donc on est
350 400 dans le monde en France on est à
peu près pour attrapes 35 salariés on
fait travailler à peu près 60 personnes
par mois et on intervient depuis
l'idéation ce qu'on appelle le dilan
thinking jusqu'à la Collective design
donc la convergence qui est technique et
la qualité perçue sur des projets
industriels alors on sait que le design
c'est très important dans l'industrie on
peut imaginer notamment pour
l'automobile ça permet d'attirer de
nouveaux clients des acheteurs
d'automobiles qu'est-ce qu'il en est du
design dans l'aéronautique parce que
finalement les gens
n'achètent pas un avion ils sont ils
prennent l'avion et ils s'intéressent
pas forcément à l'extérieur de l'avion
exactement la particularité de
l'aéronautique un petit peu comme dans
le rail c'est que le client final c'est
pas l'acheteur du des produits donc on
intervient par contre dans des produits
industriels et toute notre force et la
valeur ajoutée c'est de veiller à ce que
l'usager soit au centre du débat
toujours de A à Z du début du projet
jusqu'à la fin et qu'on oublie jamais
l'usager final dans un développement de
produits alors concrètement attrape vous
voyez il y a 35 ingénieurs qui
travaillent au quotidien sur le site de
trap sur le design en quoi consiste
l'activité alors des designers
industriels donc l'idéation le design
thinking donc c'est de la recherche du
user expérience du sketch donc tout ce
qui est dessin tout ce qui est couleur
et matières tout ce qui est modélisation
3D rapides des usages marketing aussi on
fait des clips des configurateurs des
aides à la vente et après il y a toute
une grande partie qu'on appelle coïti
design qui est la convergence qui
technique c'est comment travailler des
ingénieurs mais aussi avec le produit le
marketing les fournisseurs pour arriver
à terme sur un produit dans la rue ou
dans les airs aujourd'hui on le voit
peut-être derrière moi mais vous pensez
notamment le design par exemple un des
sièges qui a dans l'avion exactement on
travaille on a un grand client un grand
partenaire dans l'aéronautique et safran
et on travaille aujourd'hui dans la
convergence technique donc on développe
des sièges pour eux alors côté des
sièges business ou des sièges éco et
depuis pour accompagner en fait les
bureaux d'études dans le développement
des produits tout en gardant quand je
les disais tout à l'heure l'usager au
centre du débat des sièges l'outil que
vous utilisez aujourd'hui qui est de
plus en plus utiliser dans l'industrie
dite 4.0 comme on dit c'est la réalité
virtuelle on voit qu'il y a un casque
devant moi de réalité virtuelle tout à
fait alors comment vous l'utilisez la
réalité virtuelle alors vous allez
pouvoir le tester dans quelques minutes
c'est un outil de travail aujourd'hui
c'est à dire qu'en effet les usages
autour de la réalité virtuelle sont
multiples ça peut être de l'aide à
l'avant ça peut être de la formation du
manufacturing ou de
usage marketing aujourd'hui on a
présenté on présente une expérience
d'outils que l'on utilise au quotidien
en revue de design en revue de qualité
perçue pour aider en fait tous les
acteurs d'un projet à converger ensemble
donc les ingénieurs le produit le
marketing les fournisseurs autour de la
maquette numérique donc là c'est avoir
une perception humaine pour avoir un
vrai ressenti de la perception de la ce
qu'on appelle la qualité perçue finale
d'un produit et pouvoir juger et
arbitrer ce qui est important ce qui est
pas important les points durs et là où
il faut mettre du temps et donc de
l'argent et on a toujours sans cesse à
coeur de compresser des temps de
développement donc cet outil nous sert
au quotidien pour communiquer en interne
projet mais aussi pour prendre les
bonnes décisions et aider à prendre les
bonnes décisions vous m'avez proposé de
le tester on va voir le ressenti puis
vous allez nous expliquer en même temps
le fonctionnement c'est parti c'est
parti
bon ben me voilà dans l'avion à travers
cette expérience de réalité virtuelle
Frédéric comment ça se passe est-ce que
vous pouvez m'expliquer en quoi consiste
l'exercice ici alors c'est un outil de
travail donc c'est ce qu'on utilise
quotidiennement lors de ce qu'on appelle
les revues design et aussi les revues de
qualité perçue pour fédérer tous les
équipes d'un projet donc les ingénieurs
le produit le marketing les
sous-traitants autour de la macadémique
là l'idée c'est de passer le moins de
temps possible en préparation de données
3D et d'être en fait Plug and Play ou
dragon drop de la maquette 3D on va dire
Katia pour pas la nommer par exemple
directement dans cette dans cet outil
qui nous sert c'est un moteur de rendu
temps réel qui nous sert à avoir une
sortie casque une sortie en réalité
virtuelle donc c'est une revue on va
faire ce qu'on appelle par exemple des
assessment donc d'une cotation en
virtuel on va poser des pastilles
virtuelles sur le modèle 3D et à noter
faire des remarques pour pouvoir faire
des préconisations et qui après par la
suite vont être prises par les
différents acteurs du projet donc par
exemple des ingénieurs ou des ergonomes
pour régler des problèmes là le principe
ça va être d'aller chercher certains
pictogrammes pour aller tester certaines
manipulations du siège c'est ça
exactement on parle d'usagers au sein du
débat donc il y a de l'usage et donc il
y a des des cycle de vie il y a des il y
a des expériences il y a des
manipulations à faire là par exemple je
peux aller fermer la porte par exemple
par exemple exactement
la porte on va se rendre compte si on
est vraiment là c'est un siège business
vraiment isolé du reste de l'avion ou
pas si il y a des fuites de lumière par
exemple qui peuvent
limiter l'ambiance la qualité de
l'ambiance lumineuse parce que là je
vois il y a le côté privé le côté alors
là justement on vient de d'illuminer
disons la fenêtre et là on peut la
sombrer pour être calme et on teste
cette ce cas d'usage quoi voilà il faut
tout tester tout anticiper très très tôt
dans le projet le plus tôt possible
c'est pour ça qu'on passe très très
rapidement de la 2D sur les sketchs à de
la 3D et qui nous permettent en fait de
simuler très très vite et avec surtout
une perception humaine donc des angles
de vue humain des hauteurs des de
l'ergonomie et donc lever des gros
problèmes qui seraient très très coûteux
à modifier beaucoup plus tard dans le
projet pour l'expérience pour le salon
on a trouvé opportun de démontrer en
fait que l'immersif en fait notre
cerveau est très très malléable et on
peut l'amener sur des histoires ou des
expériences de façon très très réaliste
et donc si vous voulez on va on va se
lever ouvrir la porte et voir quelle
réaction vous allez avoir face au mur
la perception du vide est-ce qu'elle est
juste ou est-ce qu'elle est enfin moi
j'y allais petit pas
évident ça démontre en fait que tout ce
que l'on vit en réalité virtuelle même
en mode projet où on met pas l'accent
sur le rendu c'est pas c'est pas le but
permet d'avoir une perception humaine
qui est très très très fidèle à ce qu'il
va y avoir quelques années après quand
le produit sera réalisé produit vendu et
ici dans les airs bien merci beaucoup
Frédéric Loisel
avec plaisir je vous en prie voilà je
rappelle que vous êtes le responsable
commercial et marketing pour la marque
design industriel de SEGULA Technologies
technicon